[Musique]
comme vous le savez depuis le 1er
janvier 2016 la région alsace a disparu
au profit de la région grand est un
mariage forcé diront certains avec les
régions lorraine et champagne ardenne
nombreux sont les alsaciens qui à divers
titres s'estiment lésés par cette
réforme territoriale les présidents de
la région pourtant eux aussi alsacien
n'ayant pas réussi à convaincre une
partie de la population de ce nouveau
cadre administratif en effet un récent
sondage de l'ifop indiqué que 67% des
alsaciens seraient favorables à une
sortie du grand est et que 83% d'entre
eux approuvent ray l'idée de retrouver
une collectivité alsacienne au niveau
des conseils départementaux du bas rhin
et du haut rhin
on réfléchit depuis plusieurs mois une
évolution institutionnelle au niveau des
départements pour faire réapparaître une
collectivité nommé alsace un appel qui
semble avoir été entendu au plus haut
niveau de l'état le premier ministre a
donné aux préfets de région une mission
qu'il doit il doit rendre un rapport
d'ici la fin du printemps pour lui faire
des propositions sur l'avenir de
l'alsace
et bien entendu nous allons avant la fin
de sa mission rencontrer le préfet de
région et lui porter le projet que je
porte avec le président du bas-rhin et
nombreux élus autour de nous
parlementaires conseillers
départementaux mer mais un projet qui
sera aussi celui de toutes les
alsaciennes et de tous les alsaciens
moi je reste persuadé au fond de moi que
la sortie
du grand test serait la meilleure
solution n'est - aujourd'hui le présent
d'un public a fixé le cadre en disant
possibilité de créer une collectivité
alsace un statut particulier mais pas de
sortie pas de sortie du grand est donc
nous travaillons aujourd'hui dans ce
contexte là où nous souhaitons fusionner
à la fois les compétences des deux
départements et des compétences
transférées de l'état et des compétences
transférées de la région la collectivité
territoriale d'alsace que frédéric
bierry et brigitte klinkert appellent de
leurs voeux devrait réunir en une seule
les assemblées et administration des
départements objectif que l'alsace
retrouve une réalité institutionnelle
mais aussi qu'elles puissent pleinement
s'inscrire dans l'espace rhénan à cette
fin bien plus qu'une simple fusion des
départements
cette nouvelle collectivité serait dotée
de compétences propres à la région et à
l'état alors les compétences qui découle
de cette volonté de travailler plus avec
nos voisins suisses et nos voisins
allemands sont les compétences de
l'économie sont le tourisme
ce sont des compétences aujourd'hui
dévolues à la région nous demandons tout
ou partie des compétences économie et
tourisme à la région de l'état nous
souhaitons pouvoir récupérer les routes
nationales le transfrontalier et
l'apprentissage
des langues et notamment l'allemand pour
nous c'est un enjeu majeur il ya 3 % de
chômage en allemagne donc la possibilité
de placer les jeunes de placer des
chômeurs de longue durée en allemagne
c'est quelque chose qu'on construit mais
un des handicaps que nous vivons au
quotidien c'est la connaissance de la
langue donc nous la dynamique économique
de notre territoire la dynamique de
l'emploi dépend l'idée directement d'un
travail partenarial qu'on peut
construire avec le territoire du
bade-würtemberg et deux territoires de
balle le territoire allemand et suisse
et donc ses compétences là nous les
appelons de nos voeux de pouvoir les
récupérer
le 3 avril dernier les deux exécutifs
départementaux lancer une grande
concertation citoyenne autour de ce
projet l'ensemble des alsaciens ils sont
invités à évaluer la copie des
départements à cette fin un site web est
en ligne pour ceux qui souhaitent
participer rendez vous sur
www.lexpress.fr pour ce peu familier des
outils numériques un coupon réponse pré
timbrée est disponible dans les
magazines départementaux les citoyens
sont également invités à proposer leurs
idées
ce projet que nous construisons ensemble
le haut-rhin et le bas-rhin
nous souhaitons que ça soit pas
simplement un projet qui soit construit
par des élus mais que ce soit un projet
qui puisse être partagée par l'ensemble
des alsaciennes et des alsaciens c'est
pourquoi à partir d'aujourd'hui nous
proposons aux alsaciennes et aux
alsaciens de s'exprimer sur le projet
que nous portons et de l'enrichir pour
que ce projet soit celui de toutes les
alsaciennes et de tous les alsaciens
bien sûr cette consultation n'a pas
force de loi
elle ne pourra contraindre l'état à
aller dans un sens ou dans l'autre
au niveau des départements on la
souhaite cependant massive autant pour
appuyer leur démarche auprès du préfet
que pour en tirer des idées pour
l'avenir de l'alsace
nous ne pouvons pas considérer qu'un
projet du sens il n'est pas incarnée par
nos concitoyens donc la première volonté
c'est de dans une démarche de démocratie
d'implication et de permettre à nos
concitoyens de formuler leurs attentes
leurs remarques leurs critiques à leurs
suggestions donc ça c'est la première le
premier enjeu
le second enjeu effectivement c'est
l'occasion de montrer la mobilisation
des alsaciens pour le projet que nous
portons et qu'il peut être enrichie par
les réflexions que nos concitoyens
pourront formuler à l'occasion de ses
cent jours alors on a ces cent jours
décisifs puisque effectivement le
premier le préfet rendra sa copie au
près et au premier ministre début de
l'été c'est important pour nous que dans
cette période là on puisse encore
enrichir le projet près de 4000
personnes se sont exprimées sur le site
les propositions vont bon train plus de
2200 à ce jour nombreux sont ceux à
proposer une sortie pure et simple du
grand est
d'autres idées émergent intégration de
la moselle et du territoire de belfort à
la nouvelle collectivité renforcement de
la démocratie participative et vous vous
la voyez comment l'alsace de demain